school choice is winning in America
folks we are winning
good morning everyone and thank you very
much Rebecca we're going to start with a
little PowerPoint presentation and I'd
like to say that in 2011 school choice
winning on April fourth 2011 the Supreme
Court rejects the challenge to Arizona's
tuition scholarship tax credit the High
Court rules that because tax credits
leave money in the hands of taxpayers
they never become public funds as a
result under federal law taxpayers do
not have standing to challenge the
program 30,000 kids in Arizona 370
private schools and everybody else who's
doing this now and may do this in the
future winning boom later in the week
the Arizona Legislature increases the
amount of the tax credit for couples
from a thousand dollars to $1,500 per
couple what that means is directly the
tax that those couples pay to the state
of Arizona they can now pay to a
scholarship organization and send more
kids to private schools DC kids winning
as part of the federal budget deal last
week congress reauthorized the District
of Columbia school voucher program it'll
now be around guaranteed for five more
years and they're going to expand it
currently seventeen hundred kids in DC
at 50 private schools winning kaboom the
first local Universal voucher program
that a school board approved in Douglas
County Colorado in this program the
school board unanimously said that they
would pay tuition for hundreds of their
own students to attend private schools
the first year of the program in 2012
will give 500 kids in Douglas County
School District 45 hundred dollars to go
to the private school of their choice
indiana is set to pass the largest
school voucher program the school choice
scholarship bill passed the house and is
now being reviewed in the Senate
governor mitch Daniels has promised to
sign it and barring the exodus of the
Senate Democrats again fleeing to
another state it will become law this
legislative session the number of
scholarships available the first year
will be 7500 15,000 scholarships the
second year and by 2003 there will be an
unlimited number of kids in Indiana that
can use a voucher to go to the school of
their parents choice school choice is
winning in America folks we are winning
there's currently 20 school voucher and
tax credit programs in the nation 11 of
these or school vouchers 9 are tax
credits right now there's over seven
hundred million dollars in public funds
that now go away from the public school
monopoly and follow the kids to the
school of their parents choice over the
past five years that amount has doubled
from three hundred million dollars we've
seen a 75 percent increase in the number
of kids that have private school choice
in America in the last five years
seventy-five percent increase this
legislative session these are the states
that have voucher bills the threats are
to the unions not to us and the evidence
is in about school voucher programs
there's actually 10 empirical studies
that have used random assignment which
is the gold standard for social science
that examine outcomes for students and
voucher programs nine of those studies
found that vouchers improve student
outcomes one study found no visible
difference and what that means is in
that case those kids are doing just as
well as kids in public schools using a
voucher for about fifty percent of the
cost of their public school tuition and
there were also 19
empirical studies with random assignment
gold standard for social science that
found a positive effect for the kids
that remain in the public schools from
the competition from vouchers and again
vouchers the evidence is in when you
look at the best research out there the
school choice works kids do better in
charter schools kids are also winning
charter schools is continues to be the
largest example of education
privatization we're nonprofit groups and
private groups have contracts with
government authorizers to run schools
the school finance mechanism for charter
schools is exactly like a voucher or a
tax credit in that the money is attached
to the backs of kids the financing
mechanism works exactly the same way the
school doesn't get paid if the parents
don't choose the school and the kids
don't show up there there's 5,000
charter schools serving two million
children 500,000 kids right now at least
are on waiting lists in the United
States for charters there's 14
communities where more than twenty
percent of the kids are in charter
schools 72 communities were more than
ten percent of the kids are in charter
schools Carolyn hawks peas from Harvard
University her she's an economist there
that does education research her famous
study said that you only need six
percent of kids opting out of the public
schools to make a difference in those
public school communities that's the
level of competition that you need six
percent so we're way above that in many
many cities three cities have more than
one third of their public school
students and charters Detroit with
thirty two percent no surprise there
washington DC thirty-six percent New
Orleans has 71 percent speaking of New
Orleans it's the most market-driven
school system in the United States 71
percent of all New Orleans kids are in
charter schools seventy-seven percent of
kids and K through eight are in charter
schools what this means is no longer in
new Lauren Orleans can people argue that
chart
schools are creaming the best students
because they're serving every student in
the public school district the dropout
rate for New Orleans public schools fell
thirty-one percent from 2008 to 2010
since 2005 the dropout rate has been cut
in half fallen by fifty percent in
august of 2005 no one would have
imagined that by August of 2010 New
Orleans would be the most improved
school district in the United States in
2005 sixty-six percent of the schools
were failing in 2010 twenty-six percent
of the schools are failing and every
indicator student achievement for
reading in math ap scores for students
in high school college acceptance rate
New Orleans is doing better boom in
Louisiana we just helped pass a
statewide student based budgeting
there's now 25 districts where the
public school funds follow the kids to
the schools of their choice what we did
in Louisiana is we got 10
superintendents of different parishes
both small and large after we had been
bringing people there from other
districts to tell them about how much
better it was for principals and
superintendents when schools control
their resources and the money follow the
child after doing this for about of year
ten superintendents volunteered to do
this in their schools and they stood
about a month ago with Governor Jindal
and announced that they plan to have the
money follow the kids in their school
and Andrea Alonso who's the CEO of
Baltimore City Schools which I would
argue is becoming the best school
district in America has been very
aggressive where he went to Louisiana
with us and talked about what's happened
in his school district in four years and
he's the big guy on the left in four
years he took 600 administrators from
the central office and took a hundred
million dollars that they were paying
them and gave it to the school
and then the principles before he came
four years ago controlled four percent
of their budget they now control eighty
percent of their budget and in those
four years in Baltimore they have cut
the african-american dropout rate so
four years ago 1,500 african-american
males dropped out of high school in 2010
it was 497 because you know what when
the money follows the kids and you have
at risk african-american kids that are
having a hard time if those kids leave
your high school guess what else leaves
your high school though money incentives
work when the money follows the kids
schools rapidly change their behavior Oh
see I did it finally the last
development I think that is very
exciting is what's known as parent
trigger laws in America and what a
parent trigger is is that in an
individual school if 51% of the parents
vote to do something different in
California with their school the school
district has to do what they want so the
first school was mckinley elementary
school which is a small school in
compton unified compton unified is a
school district that in 2010
one-point-five percent of their students
made it to college let me say that again
one-point-five percent of compton high
school kids that actually graduated made
it to college so you can see why parents
there might want to do something
different with their schools so
basically what the parent trigger lob it
allows a grassroots efforts by parents
to vote in new management for their
schools McKinley Elementary voted to
have a local charter school manage their
schools then compton unified said we
refuse to accept this petition even
though it was california law and they
said not only that we're going to
enforce a verification system on parents
where every parent has to come down to
the district office and be interviewed
and show their identification and prove
even though their kids are obviously
enrolled in the school and this is
in a community where it's almost one
hundred percent Hispanic parents and
families and you can imagine the
intimidation of trying to do something
better for your school and then having a
school district tell you that you have
to prove who you are before that you
will accept that vote a Superior Court
judge two weeks ago issued an injunction
against Compton unified for violating
the constitutional rights of those
parents and they ordered Compton to
count the parent trigger trigger
petitions and signatures and this
represents a huge victory for parents
have Compton for parents of California
and for parents of the nation and now
that there's a parent trigger law in
California states across the country or
replicating that school where an
individual parents at an individual
schools don't have to wait for the state
or the district to do something to make
their school better they can take it
into their own hands in 2011 school
choice winning
so for the next part of our presentation
I'm actually going to do a little
interview with Clare Mullen who's the
Senior Program Officer for the Gleason
Family Foundation and this year at the
reason foundation we were really in for
national school choice week and in our
Washington DC office Nick Gillespie
Gillespie helped me to have a very good
presentation with Virginia Walden Ford
who's the founder of the Washington DC
scholarship with support from the
Gleason Family Foundation recent TV
during national school choice week I
think released 25 school choice
education videos because of nick during
national school choice week really
awesome interviews with people like Jeb
Bush from Florida and Joel Klein and
superintendents across the nation like
Deborah grist you heard of her in Time
magazine the Rhode Island superintendent
that when the high school that she was
trying to make change in would not do
what she asked she fired the entire
staff of the high school because they
were not willing to make change for kids
so those are the kind of people our
reason TV videos were able to interview
and then we also screened a showing of
the lottery which was up for an Academy
Award for documentary in Los Angeles
that really shows the pain that parents
go to when they're on a waiting list and
they can't get their kids into a charter
school so now I'm going to turn over to
Claire and I'm going to ask her a couple
questions and the first question I have
for Claire really is just tell us how
national school choice week came about
why now why national school choice week
I i would like to tell a little story
funny story about how national school
choice week was actually conceived I
have two daughters that are in public
school in California and last year on
March third they came home from school
and they said mommy mommy tomorrow is a
really important day and I said why is
that and they said because we have to
help the teachers and I thought oh
okay we'll see what happens so the next
day I Drive my kids up to the turning
circle and they get out at the curb and
all the teachers are lined up they're
not in the classroom they're all lined
up standing there waiting for the
parents and so I roll down my window and
I put my hand out and they give me the
stack of California Teacher Association
propaganda basically so I drove into the
office where I met with my colleague
Tracy Gleason and by the time I got
there I was fuming because they had
basically you know indoctrinated my
children and that this all this
propaganda that they were putting out
was about the budget the beginning of
the budget cuts and they had what they
called that day was a day of action in
California and they had organized all of
their members and their teachers to
protest and saying that these cuts hurt
kids and you can't cut our budgets we
need more money and they even went so
far as to lay down on the freeway on the
bay bridge during rush hour traffic and
basically they brought San Francisco to
a standstill and it was all over the
media it was all over the news it was a
huge story and I said to Tracy I said
where is our day of action wyd why don't
we have this kind of organized action
and she said well we should do that
let's do a week and let's call it
national school choice week so that is
that's lit quite literally how it was
born and basically the idea behind it is
to take all of these fantastic
organizations that are working brilliant
work all across the country for decades
they've been striving to bring school
choice and education reform to America
and national school choice week is
really a marketing tool whereby they can
raise awareness and shine a spotlight on
all the wonderful work that they do one
of the the characteristics of the
movement is that all these groups
they've been working largely
independently and they all have a
different focus some may focus on
charter schools some may focus on vouch
some may focus on anti-union so it's
been hard for them to really coordinate
and organize to work together but really
the end goal is not the same for all of
us which is to bring excellent education
to all children in America I think I'd
like to play a little video actually we
had our so we had our first national
school choice week which was in January
and we kicked off at the reason DC
offices and when all across the country
and you're going to see some of the
events and some of the media attention
and just will play the video
from january twenty third through
january 29 2011 more than 200
organizations came together for a week
of action to shine a spotlight on
effective education options for all
children first-ever national school
choice week national school choice week
this is national school choice week this
is school choice week school choice week
during the week over 150 events
celebrating school choice were held
across the nation from Sacramento to
cincinnati orlando to oregon and as far
away as Alaska and Hawaii people
celebrated the week in their own ways
oftentimes using an abundance of
creativity rallies to state capitals
town hall meetings movie screenings book
club meetings concerts beach parties
online events barbecues expose pub
nights even grandma's for charter
schools coffee houses tens of thousands
of advocates parents and concerned
citizens participated and thousands
began following national school choice
week on facebook twitter and linkedin
thought leaders from across a broad
social and political spectrum added
their voices to the bipartisan call for
reform this is what we need education
was my ticket in terms of the American
dream how long John Boehner and I'm all
in for national school choice week I am
in for national school choice week i'm
in for national school choice week i'm
in for school choice week the news
coverage was constant reaching all 50
states and over 34 million americans
from national television to local papers
school choice week resulted over 550
news stories the first-ever national
school choice week officially wrapping
up today the gold put the spotlight on
education reform I think national school
choice week is pointing out the people
that we all have to work together for
the benefit of children it's one of the
issues one of the rare issues where
Republicans and Democrats agree young
and old agree no matter where you live
urban suburban and rural hundreds of
school choice supporters rallied on the
steps of the state capitol today
hundreds of people packed into a North
Raleigh hotel to talk about the future
of education in North Carolina hundreds
of
vania residents are headed to Harrisburg
this morning to fight for school choice
families took their push for school
choice to the Georgia state capitol
today I'm sitting in Chicago today where
there are over a thousand parents that
were rallying for school choice outside
of the Chicago School Board meeting it's
a national school choice week scarf
lawmakers took notice 11 governors
declared the week school choice week in
their states and signed proclamations
making it official I groundbreaking
legislation was introduced in many
states I am humbled to join this group
of state lawmakers from both parties who
are coming together to focus on and
highlight the fact that it is national
school choice week and we want to move
the ball on school choice in our great
state of Missouri we wanted to kind of
pair this press conference with national
school choice week school choice week
was even brought to the floor of the US
House of Representatives I rise today in
honor of a grassroots movement is
currently taking place all across our
great nation the celebration of national
school choice week three award-winning
documentaries the cartel waiting for
superman and the lottery played a
significant role in the success of the
week over 50 screenings of the
documentaries took place across the
country Bob Bowden director of the film
The Cartel attended many of these events
himself as part of an expansive speaking
tour the education revolution tour
visited 11 major cities and held
townhall meetings with panel discussions
by well-known talk radio hosts community
leaders and education reform activists
the events drew thousands of attendees
and gained widespread national media
attention when Lisa said that this
session would be called the tipping
point for school choice I was really
excited because that's that's what
national school choice week is all about
it's an event-driven movement to raise
awareness and from the ground up I I
feel like as a sub
and soccer mom myself before I was
working at the foundation I had never
heard of school choice I thought my
school was fabulous you know I pay a lot
of money in taxes and I might house was
pretty expensive i think my school has
to be you know awesome so I think we
have a difficult job because the people
that will benefit first and most from
school choice really have the least
political the smallest political voice
it's the pits the people like me who are
voting and involved and you know
educated and living in the suburbs that
are not really bringing pressure to bear
on legislators to make changes in
education so that is job number one for
us it's really to to reach my
demographic and bring us closer to the
tipping point and you know create the
social epidemic that will make this
happen okay I'm going to ask you to one
file story ok so the would be right the
beloved movie has a little controversy
of its own where I think claire has
coined it would be gate and it happened
in Idaho and I and this just happened
last week right so I thought that it
might just see how the yellow scarves
are causing trouble around the United
States the lobbies so already the the
union's fear this scarf you should wear
it with pride you should because this
little three dollar scoff last week in
Idaho on the penultimate day of their
session they were voting on a charter
bill to lift the cap from six a year
they were trying to remove this cap so
they went out for lunch and during lunch
one of the Idaho school choice groups
they're handed out the would be to the
legislators and when they came back into
the session they were wearing these so
and you have to obtain permission to
distribute anything so correct
permission
been obtained however that information
had not made it to the floor in time
mysteriously so the the floor the
Minority Leader the Democrat stood up
and was outraged that there were
promotional gifts and these scarves were
on the floor and they were swaying the
vote and that was that was against the
house rules and he managed to table the
bill and there was only one day
remaining in the session so the bill was
tabled we got a google alert about this
while we were at a meeting and I just
couldn't even believe it I'm like oh the
whoopie has killed the charter school
bill so the next day on the last day of
the session they reintroduce a new bill
which did passed the first stage but
they didn't have time to put it through
so essentially I you know the message
here is that the unions have been paying
their politicians way too much they
could just get their vote with a
three-dollar scarf so
pretty powerful piece of fleece right
here